hey guys in this video we're going to talk about
hummus and after I'm done with this video chances
are you're going to probably drive out and get
some hummus to start consuming it because it's
quite an amazing combination of six ingredients
chickpea tahini olive oil lemon garlic and sea
salt now when you buy hummus read the ingredients
and make sure it does not consume anything else
like preservatives and chemicals and soy oil okay
don't get that one give get it basically just
with these ingredients now let's just first talk
about the chickpea garbanzo bean it actually has
properties to improve insulin resistance it helps
your blood sugar so even though there's a good
amount of carbohydrate it will not affect your
blood Sugar's too much at all I have diabetics
that consume this and it doesn't really affect
them so that's the good news plus if we add these
tahini and olive oil that fat buffers any type
of you know spike in insulin okay now I'm sure
there's a point where you can consume too much
but here's the key is when you consume hummus
make sure you use vegetables not pita dip I'm
sorry okay so it also has 75% in soluble fibers
when this fiber goes into the large colon these
microbes start consuming it and they make this
thing called butyric acid which then feeds the
colon cells this acid is also really good for
insulin resistance so it's going to help you in
two ways now chickpeas are also high in molybdenum
which also helps the liver detoxify certain
things like heavy metals and also byproducts
or toxins from Candida so that's pretty cool and
then we get to tahini button that sesame seed oil
sesame seed oil has a lot of properties that sisal
vitamins but it's high in a methionine which is an
amino acid which is good for depression and an
anti gray hair factor so if you're deficient in
this amino acid you can get gray hair and I'm
not saying it's going to help your hair but it
could affect it gallbladder support omega-3 acids
and a lot of other nutrition it's kind of similar
to peanut butter but it's more bland olive oil
I've done a seminar on that restore the video
that recently anti-inflammatory supports the
cardiovascular systems high in vitamin E okay
I get the extra virgin lemon lemon is really
good for preventing kidney stones it's also
high in vitamin C and has a lot of other things as
well garlic it's probably the most powerful anti
microbial things you can consume and anti-cancer
and there's a lot of phytonutrients I mean it's
good for parasites and fungus and you name it and
then we got the sea salt sea salt is composed of
94 minerals so can I mean this is an incredible
combination of ingredients to make hummus so it's
okay to consume it even on a ketogenic diet
so okay guys in summary you can either find
some from the health of store or make it your
own and put a recipe down below check it out